in all states in all
cantons like ducks
hi my name is bill ackman i am the
CEO of Pershing Square
capital management and I'm here to
talk to you about everything you need to know
about finance and investment I'm going to
do in an hour and you're going to be ready
to begin with so let's start so that
you can have a better understanding about
finances and some basic terms
associated with a business and invest in
a business I will use the example of a
lemonade stand let's start a
business together let's open a post
of lemonades so the reason why
he used the example of the lemonade stand
it's because it's a very easy way to
understand the basic points of
business how to understand the
operating a business as a
business generates profits that involves
by raising capital to start a
company what to do when it is ready
to decide to monetize your investment or
remove some money from the table and
to be able to understand each one of these
concepts through the very simple lens
of a small business as a position of
Let's start a business
together we are going to start a company and
we are going to start a lemonade stand
so today I do not have any money like that
that I'm going to have to raise money from
investors to throw the black
so how am I going to do that good I'm going to
form a corporation is a small
presentation of documents that you make with
state and create the name of your business
we'll call it the lemonade stand
I see and we are going to collect money from
external investors we need a
little money to start so
We are going to start our business with a thousand
actions we simply invent the
number and we will sell 500 more shares
for one dollar each to an investor
now the investor will put 500
dollars we will put the name and
the idea we are going to have a thousand shares he
he will have 500 shares he will have a
third of the business for its $ 500
so how much is our business worth
good start is worth 1,500 dollars
we have 500 dollars in the bank or more
thousand dollars because I came up with the
idea of ​​the company now I'm going to
need a little over 500 dollars like this
what am I going to do I am going to borrow
some money I'm going to borrow from
a friend and he's going to lend me $ 250 and
we are going to pay you 10 percent of
interest per year for said loan now
because we borrow money instead
from simply selling more good shares
because when borrowing money
we keep more actions
to us so that if the business
is successful we will end up with a greater
percentage of earnings now let's see
how the business looks on a piece of
paper let's see something called the
balance sheet and a balance sheet
says where the company is
what are your assets what is your
liabilities and what is your net worth or
accounting capital so we take the
active in this case we have put together 500
dollars in exchange for the 500 dollars the
person who put the money just got
one third of the business the other two
thirds is our property to start
the company are 1000 dollars for the
business value of the business
we borrow 250 dollars but let's go
to duty 250 dollars that's a liability like that
that we got 500 dollars in cash
for sale of shares 250 dollars
obtained by a loan and we owe a
loan of 250 dollars and we have a
corporation that you have and you'll see it in
the graph an accounting capital of 1500
dollars so that's our point of
start, let's continue
what we need to do to start
our good company we need a
lemonade stand and that will cost us
approximately $ 300 that's called
a fixed asset unlike the
lemons or sugar or water this is
something like a building that one buys and
one builds wears away with time
but it is a fixed asset and we need
some inventory that we need to
to make good lemonade we need sugar
water lemons glasses small containers
and maybe some napkins and
enough supplies for let's say
have 50 gallons of lemonade to be able to
start our business now 50
gallons does not yield for 800 glasses of
lemonade and we're ready to start
let's see the balance sheet so now
we have spent 500 dollars
we have 250 dollars left in the bank but
our fixed assets are now 300
dollars for our lemonade stand
our inventory is 200 dollars
those are the supplies and things the
lemons that we need to make the
lemonade the commercial value has not
changed a thousand dollars so our
total assets are $ 1750 and
we still owe 250 dollars to the person who
he lent us the money the accounting capital
It has not changed like that
we have not made any money yet everything
what we have done is take money and what
we have converted into other assets that
we are going to need to be successful with
our business of lemonade stands
now let's make some assumptions about
How will the business eventually go?
let's assume we can sell each
glass for a dollar and it will cost us
approximately $ 530 a year on
staff to attend our position of
lemonades now let's see the state of
results the statement of results speaks
about profitability over income
what the business generates what are the
expenses and what is left to the owner of the
company so we have a position of
lemonade we are selling 800 glasses of
lemonade in our position charging a
dollar so we are generating 800
dollars a year in revenue and we're
spending 200 dollars on inventory there
a concept here called cpp cox that
means cost of products sold
we have depreciation because our
Lemonade stand is abused a little
over time and it will wear
completely in five years so it's
depreciates five years we have our
labor costs for people who
empty the lemonade
and collect the money from the clients we have
a gain that is the
ivette that means profit before
of taxes and interest of 10 dollars
it's something like our gain before
of business taxes so no
we made a lot of money since we took the
Earnings before taxes of 10
dollars and we compare it to our
income and its margin of approximately
1.3 percent is not a profit
particularly high now we have to
pay interest on our debts and
we have lost 15 dollars and then no
we have taxes but in the end
we end up losing money
we must continue investing in the
business we have lost money in the
first year it's time to give us
expired
well let's think a moment let's do
some projections on how it will look
the company during the next years
let's assume that we take all the money that
generates the business and we will use it to
buy more lemonade stands
so that we can grow let's assume that
we are not going to take any money from the
company we are not going to pay dividends
let's keep all the money in the
company and we will reinvest it in
create our brand we can charge a
little more every year so let's go up
Our prices approximately five
cents more for each glass of lemonade
every year and we're going to assume that we're going to
sell 5% more glasses of course per year
so let's take on growth
let's look at the company now
when you see the graph you will see that in year 1
we started with a lemonade stand and
then we add one per year and for the year
5 we get to 7 because we have a huge
expansion plan our price for
glass goes up 5 cents per year and our
incomes go from 800 dollars and they begin
to grow pretty fast and the
growth comes from the increase in
prices of lemon cups
and it also comes from opening more positions like that
that by year 5 we have almost 8000
dollars in revenue our costs are
relatively constant comprising
lemonade and sugar
those are roughly $ 702
we have depreciation since more and more
posts begin to wear out we have
labor costs but for the year
5 the business is doing quite well
we went from a margin of 1.3 percent to
a margin of more than 28 percent the
business is adjusted to its size
We are beginning to cover some of
our costs are still growing
We are paying 20 to 5 dollars per year
in interest for our loan and
we have earnings before taxes
after interest for 2,300 dollars
at the end of year 5 so we put 500
dollars to the business we borrow 250
and for year 5 we are having a
profit of 2 thousand 300 dollars that sounds
pretty good now we have to pay
taxes to the government this is
approximately 35 percent and
we generate as net income or other
word for earnings of 1500 dollars
for the fifth year and approximately one
dollar the action
so if you think about it, our friend put
500 dollars to buy 500 shares he
paid a dollar and after five years
be our business elevates as we expect
will be earning one dollar per share in
earnings
that sounds like a very good deal now let's see
the statement of cash flow to
become the most profitable business
we generate more and more cash and the
cash accumulates in the company
we spent $ 500 in cash in the
company to more than 2 thousand dollars in
effective during the period the balance
initial general had a capital
accounting for $ 490 dollars but at
become more profitable business
the profits summed up money
they added to the assets of the company
our liabilities have not changed and the
business continues to create value with
time again at the end of the five
years we have four thousand dollars of
accounting capital and that's almost three
times what we had when we started
is this a good business or a bad business
how to know if it is good or bad
thing you have to think about is what
type of earnings we are achieving
compare
how much money did the company enter this
It is a business that we have evaluated in 1500
dollars when we start someone put
500 dollars for a third of the company
we gave it a value of 1500 dollars but
At the end of year 5 we are earning more
of $ 1500 so that's more than
100 percent yield for the
money that we put to the company that
it's really a high number we spend
two thousand one hundred dollars in capital
building the lemonade stands and
we won two thousand 336 dollars in five
years for the capital that we invest that
It is more than 100 percent performance
of capital that is a very performance
attractive earnings have grown to
a very fast rate one hundred fifty and
five per year this is a true
growing company and our
profitability went from 1.3 percent to
28.6 percent in the fifth year that
it sounds pretty attractive and it is so
let's see the person who gave the loan
that person put 250 dollars and the
business has been profitable we have been able
pay your interest of 10% per year 25
dollars a year and he's happy because
put 252
is receiving a 10% yield
for your loan and the business is worth more than
$ 250 we have obtained more than that
in cash as a result they are in a
safe position but have only won one
10% for your money compare now that
with the capital investor the
person who bought the shares of the
company that person earned a dollar for
action in five years versus one
investment of one dollar per share so
is earning more than 100 percent or
approximately 100 percent of
return on your investment versus just
10 percent of who loans so
who got a better good deal
obviously the investor in capital
because the capital investor
because he got the right to earn a lot
more than the lender the answer is
that I take more risk if the business
failed the lender had the right to
the first $ 250 worth of that
leave the company's liquidation
so if I sold the positions of
lemonade and only got $ 250 the
lender recovers all your money and
obtained its 10% yield while the
business worked he got back to
its 200
to dollars but the investor of
capital the person who bought the
actions is left with nothing because it comes
after the lender so what is
the difference between debt and capital
debts tend to be an investment more
sure since one has a claim
greater by the assets of the company and
it happens in many different ways has
heard of mortgage debt for a
home that is a secured loan
insured for a house but can have
a mortgage debt on a building
of a company there is principal debt there is
lesser debt there is intermediate debt there is
convertible debt but in the end everything is
good debt in different orders of
priority in a company and the rate that
Cobra is inverse in relation to its
values ​​to better the value lower the risk
lower will be the interest rate that has
right to receive between minor is the
level of the loan the higher the rate of
interest to which you are entitled to receive
but you can avoid complexity in what
The only thing you need to think about is that
debts are first the loan more
sure but your chance of profit
is limited now capital too
it comes in different forms there is something
called preferred capital or shares
preferred to common capital or shares
common and again the actions and the
coffee
they are basically synonyms there are options
but it's not worth talking about them today
the important thing is that capital gets
everything that remains after paying the
debts so a claim is called
residual now the good thing about the
residual claim is that if the
business grows in value you do not owe
more to your lenders but all that
value goes to the shareholders so the
question is why the lender
he was willing to only take 10%
when the capital won a much rate
greater performance and the answer is
that when the business started there was no
way to know if you are going to succeed or not
and the lender made a bet on the
that if the business failed because they could
sell the lemonade stand you know
it cost $ 300 to do it they would have something
of lemons
some lemonade even if they sold with
a much lower price than the dollar that
originally projected the lender
he felt quite comfortable that
I would receive your money back while
that the shareholder really was
taking a risk is betting on the
profitability of the company and is
taking a risk that if it fails
you will lose the full investment so
they have the right to obtain a return
greater or have the potential to have a
higher yield in the event that the
business was successful so let's talk
about the risk
he knows a lot of people who talk about the
risk in the stock market the
risk of stock prices
going up and down every day we do not believe
that this is the risk that should be
focus on the risk in which it should be
focus is on your investment in a
business what is the probability that
lose your money is going to be a loss
permanent when you think about a
investment versus another do not worry
whether the price goes up or down much to
short term what matters is finally
recover your money you will get a
return on your investment how to think
at risk a way of thinking about
the risk is to compare your risk with
other alternatives so you can buy
government bonds government bonds
government are considered today
lowest investment risk and the
US treasury issues debt to ten
years three years and five years there is a rate
of established interest and today a bonus of
the treasury to ten years gives him to win
approximately a yield of 3%
you give your government a thousand dollars and
you receive $ 30 in interest
earned at the end of the 10 years you
he receives his thousand dollars back so
it is very very safe and that creates a kind
of base obviously if it's going to be a
loan can lend money to
government and win 3
good if you lend the money to a position
lemonade will want something more
significant so in this case the
lender charges a 10% rate of
interest because 10% because he wants to win
something greater than what you can earn
lending the government because a business
at the start of a lemonade stand is
a business with greater risk the
investors in capital think about
things in a similar way so how much
riskier is the highest business
will be the rate of return that the
investor in capital will wait and
the lower the business risk
less will be the performance that the
investor in capital will wait and
investors in capital do not
get interests in the same way
what lenders do what
investors get in capital
is the potential to receive dividends
during the life of a company let's talk
of raising capital when the
lemonade business the point of this
was making money first of all the
business is still doing well for having
started the business create the name and the
concept hire all people
do not earn anything so the business has not
grown in value but where is my
money i need money to buy a
car for example so I want to buy
a car for four thousand dollars which
are my options that I can
well we have taken all the cash that
has generated the business and reinvested it
in business now the good news is
that we have seized all that money we have
could have used it to buy more
lemonade stands and those positions
lemonade are more productive and they make
grow business value faster and
faster and my alternatives could
include also instead of growing
the business so fast instead of
invest in more lemonade stands yo
I could have just been paid
dividends to myself now the good
news about this is that I
get money along the way
the bad news about that argument
is that the business does not grow as
quickly and if you have a business that
it's as profitable as this position
lemonade and we can earn hundreds of
dollars with each new post what
It makes sense to continue investing well
how to maintain my business and do it
grow taking advantage of the opportunities
but taking some money from
budget well how do I do it
sell my business from lemonade stands
now I started with this new york 'such
there is someone in new yersey who wants
buy me to consolidate my company
lemonade stands the problem with that
is that once sold I can no longer
participate in the opportunity to follow
ahead
in this business I think it's going to be very
successful over time therefore it is
an alternative the other alternatives
instead of selling 100% of the business
is to sell a piece of the business too
can I do it privately can I
find an investor who wants
buy an action in the company and if the
business worth enough
I can sell you a piece of the business and
we can guess the other alternative is
that I can turn the business into
public an initial peo public offering
the abbreviation means for the offer
initial public and its initial because it is
the first time a company is done
public go public means
sell shares to the broad public and
general instead of finding a
investor to buy an action in
the company and it's an offer because it
we are offering the opportunity to the
people to participate what is
interesting is that a peo does not make a rich
no one all he really does is
take a business they already own and sell
a piece of this to the public and what
list in the bag when you decide that
You want to return your business to the public
have to reveal a lot of
information to the public in order to
attract investors to
participate the securities and exchange
commission study
very carefully this booklet and they are going to
make sure that they disclose the various
risks associated with investing in the
company and you will also have the
opportunity to talk about the business
that can be an exciting time
for you because when you sell shares to
public in most cases is the
way to get the optimal price more
high for the company but you do not have to
sell 100% of business to
public in fact you could normally
sell only a small percentage
you can keep the rest you can
maintain control of the company
you can raise money from the offer and
you can use that money to buy
the car we were talking about like that
that before you decide to make it public
or even selling it is probably a
good idea to find out how much is your
company ok let's talk about the
valuation or how to value a business a
way to determine the value of your
business is to compare it with other companies
similar the stock market is a
very interesting place to do this
comparison a stock market is a
list of companies that have sold
actions to the public and can be consulted
in the new york times or the wall street
journal or online in the section
yahoo or google finance or others
sites and find the prices of the
mcdonald's coca-cola actions and what
what the stock prices say
the value of a company and how to find out
the value of the company you have to see
where is the price of the shares and
count how many actions are
outstanding outstanding shares
will be tendered in several documents
submitted to the commission ss
values ​​multiply times
pending actions for the price of
the shares and tells you what the price is
that you are paying for the assets of
the company if we go back to our
example of our small position of
lemonade we have 1500 shares in
circulation that we have sold
initially for a dollar one third of
them to an investor and the company
initially it had a value of 1,500
dollars what is the value of the business today
Well, one way to find out is to look for it
other companies lemonade stands
let's assume that other companies in
lemonade stands have sold in the
public private market for a price of
10 times the profits or 10 times the
profit that will give you a sense of value
let's also assume that other
Lemonade stand companies are
doing business 20 times the
income in the stock market well
we won one dollar per share in the fifth
year if we put a multiple of 20 in that
dollar the business has a value of according to
the comparable parameter about 20 dollars
per share
we have 1500 shares outstanding
multiply 1500 by 20 now our
business is worth 30 thousand dollars so
we have a company that started with 1500
and that five years later its value is
of 30 thousand dollars what is really
very good well as we raise four thousand
dollars if that is the right value for
our business good if we have sold
two hundred of our 200 shares of
our actions that today are 20 dollars
per share we could increase the 4 thousand
dollars that we're talking about that
is what that would do what would happen if we have
sold two hundred of our shares
in the market well our
interests in the business would go down because
today we have sixty-six and two
thirds percent or two thirds of the
One third of the company is owned by
private investors if we have sold
shares in the market if we have sold
two hundred of the actions that
we would have had our property
would go from 67 percent to 53 percent
so the good thing about this is that even
we would have control of the company because
Most public companies
own a majority of the shares you
allows you to control the business in the
future but because the company is now
owned by public shareholders
you have to make sure that your
interests are properly
represented by what you have to
have a board of directors a group
individuals that represent the interest of
the shareholders who have the duty
make sure that its shareholders are
treated correctly and does not have
the same degree of flexibility that
you had when you were a private company
because you have other shareholders in the
what do you need to think but the benefit
of the upv offer for sale is that
the stock now would be liquid there would be a
market that would change in the markets
public and then eventually if I
I would like to sell more shares could
do it or if new ones come
investors they could buy
actions and our actions now
they would be more liquid to feel better
about my business regarding me
ability to at some point exit or
even raise more money or you could
sell shares pretty easily in
the market because every day I can see the
price on the web or in the 'new york
times' or on other sites and I can
find out what my business is worth well in
what is your business
the purpose of the example of our
Lemonade stand is going to give them
investors an idea about what
companies are the ones that make profits what
that the various reports provide
the investors so that they
determine what each company and the
purpose of this conference is for
tell you some of the things in which
you need to think when it comes to wanting
invest some of your
money if you want to invest in a position
of lemonade or in a company in the
market let's assume that at 22 you already have
a good job instead of spending your
money in artifacts or in an apartment
luxury or one not so luxurious or go out to
drink you decide to save some money and
start investing
let's say you can save 10 thousand
dollars at 22 and that you can earn a
10% of the profitability of that money
between now the time to retire how much
you would have in 43 years the answer is that
If you put aside those 10 thousand dollars,
you save a penny more than you already
you have invested and what you earned from 10
percent of that money per year would have
600 thousand dollars at 43 years old and the reason
of this is that in year 1 your 10 thousand
dollars would become 11 years your
$ 11,000 could grow by 10% and
that way he would have earned interest not only in
the main and original but it would have
interest accrued on interest
earned the previous year and that effect
allows money to grow from a
almost unstoppable way now obviously
If you win more than 10% you can win even
higher profitability now that's if
you just set aside ten thousand dollars to the
22 you would have saved 600 thousand dollars in
years that's pretty good what happens if
you had to wait until 32 the
problem is that for the 33 only
you would have 232 thousand dollars maybe that's not
it's enough to retire, so what
important here is if you want to be
investor one of the most active
valuable we have today at 18 or 19
years of age is youth should you
start early so your money
can grow over time
What would happen if you could win 15%?
to explain the capitalization and how
powerful is remember that with 10% to
the 43 years would have 600 thousand dollars that
it's pretty good but if you win 15%
you would have more than 4 million now you are
in a pretty good position and
obviously smart decisions
about where to put your money makes a
big difference in what your
retirement assets
obviously you can save more than 10 thousand
dollars if you could save 10 thousand each
year your wealth would be absolutely
huge just to have fun let's see
this example if you were one of the
largest investors in the world
warren buffett is a good example if
you could earn 20% per year for 43
years you would have 25 million dollars the
original investment of 10 thousand dollars
would increase more than 2,500 times during that
period only by obtaining a
20 percent return
Albert Einstein said the most force
the powerful in the universe is the interest
The key is to start early
earn an attractive return and not lose
money and you're going to have a very
nice
well now let's talk about the
risk of losing money let's assume that
to try and get a 20 for
hundred percent you've taken many
risks and it turns out that you know it from
Every 12 years, you can lose the
half the money because you had bad
luck in the market or you took
unintelligent decisions good your
25 million dollars at 20% now only
would be worth one million 8 in 43 years like this
that a key success factor here is not
just invest by investing but not trying
of getting the highest performance
avoiding significant losses during
that period is fine as it says
warren buffett the number one rule of
the investment rules is never to lose
money and the number two is never to forget
rule number one so if you can
avoid losses and get a return
attractive with time you will have
a lot of money if you can stick to this
rule for a long period of time
well as being a successful investor
I'm assuming you're not going to enter
investing business I'm assuming that
are you going to be a doctor, a lawyer, or are you going
to pursue your passion but you're going to
have some money that you will save in the
time and I'm going to give you my advice about
subject a council not necessarily
definitive but it is the advice that could
give my sister my grandmother in what
it should be done to be in the same
position I think that probably is
the right way to think number 1
how do you avoid losing money what are
good business to invest my first
advice is despite the story about
the lemonade stand avoid investing in
Lemonade stands avoid investing in
business launched very
recently where the prospects do not
they are very well known because they do not
You need to earn 100% a year to
have a fortune, just invest in
an attractive return on 10 15 percent
for a long period of time and you
money grows very significantly
Then how to avoid investments more
risky, my advice would be to invest in
public securities invest in companies
listed companies that trade in the
stock market because because the
business tend to be better
established have to comply with
certain obstacles before turning
public
the shares are liquid so you can
change your mind if you want to sell if
you invest in a private position of
lemonade it's hard to find someone
to get you out of that investment unless
that the business becomes fabulously
profitable so this is my advice
number one invest in public companies
number two you should invest in business
that you can understand what I mean
with this is that there are a lot of
companies with which you have treatment in the
course of your day and of your personal life already
whether it is warehouses that
you know because you like to buy there or
that is a product the ipad that already
do you know and what do you think is a great
product you have to understand how the
company makes money if the company is
too complicated and you do not understand how
they make money they have even had a
great trajectory better avoid it a lot
people thought that enron was a company
incredible because he seemed to have a good
history but very few people are
they understood how I earned money is a
good idea to avoid those other companies
very important criterion is that you should
investing at a reasonable price could
be a fabulous business that has had
success for a long period of time
but if you pay too much for him you're not going to
earn a very good return and return
and the last advice is that you should
in a business that could theoretically
be yours forever if the market of
values ​​will close its doors by close to
10 years would not be a catastrophe that
I mean with this if you're going to combine
your money based on a 10 or 15 for
percent return during a period
43 years old you really want a business
that you can be an owner forever
I would like to constantly have to spend
from one business to the next and which are
the business that you can own for
always good there are very few who can
meet that standard a good example is
cocacola the good thing about cocacola is that
it's a relatively easy business to
understand you understand how cocacola does
money correctly sells a
syrup formula to bottlers and
business establishments and earn a
benefit every time you serve a
cocacola people have drunk a lot of coca
colá for a very long period the
population of the world is growing
sold in almost all countries of the
world and every year people drink more
cocacola and it's a very easy business to
understand and also a business that is
unlikely to have a competition
to take it out of the market as a result
of technology or someone else's
new product has been with us
for a long time people
parents have become accustomed to the taste
they give it to their children and you can wait
that the brand is maintained I think it's a
good example another good example could
being mcdonald's you can not love the
mcdonald's burgers but it's a
business that has existed for 50 years
and you understand how they make money they make those
small boxes rent to the franchisees
they charge royalties in exchange for the name
from who sells the hamburgers and
french fries and you know that people have
that eating your food is a cost
Relatively low quality is
pretty good and they keep growing every
year I think the coherent message here
is to try to find a business that
can you understand that it is not
particularly complicated that you have a
successful long-term history that wins
an attractive benefit and you can
grow over time what are the
key things you should look for in a
business as I say it will last forever
we create a company that sells a
product or service that people
need it to be something unique and that it
have loyalty to this product or brand
in particular and that people are
willing to pay a premium for them and
another good example could be a business
of sweets while people are
willing to buy generic versions
of many types of products
food
sugar flour do not need to buy the
Brand product when it comes to
candy people do not have to buy
the version of wallmart or of kmart
they want the chocolate bar jersey or
the cadbury chocolate bar want
to the brand and are willing to pay
a higher sum to get it and that
is in my opinion the key you want the
product is unique you do not want it to be a
merchandise that everyone can sell
because when selling a merchandise
anyone can sell it and can
sell it at a better price and it's very
hard to make a profit like this if you're
investing long-term you want
invest in companies that have very little
debt in one of our examples
previous we talked about our position of
lemonade and there are 250 dollars of debt that
they do not put too much pressure on the post
of lemonade from the company but if
it would have been a thousand dollars and we would have
had bad streaks the business could
have broken for lack of payment the
shareholders could have been
annihilated
so if you can find a company
that can make attractive profits
that does not have a lot of debt and that generates
many more benefits than those
they need to pay the interest of your
debt then you found a place
sure to invest your money
a long period you want the companies
have what are called barriers of
entrance you want a business wherever
difficult for someone tomorrow
put a new company to compete
with yours and throw yourself out going back
to the example of coca-cola coca-cola has
such a strong presence in the market
people already know that when they go to
a restaurant they order a cocacola and they
they give a coke it is very difficult to
someone else enter this clear circle
that of course there are pepsi and other
soda brands but the pepsi have
been circulating for a long time and the
Coca cola and the pepsi have continued
existing side by side during long
years so when you're thinking about
choose a company make sure you get
sell a product or service that is
difficult for someone to do better than
yours and that no one can think of
want to change you for another product in the
future you also want the companies
are not particularly sensitive to
factors from outside called factors
extrinsic that you can not control well
that if a business were affected
dramatically if the price of a
particular merchandise or if the rates of
interest go up and down constantly or
If there was any change in the prices of
the currency you want a company that is
pretty immune to what
is happening in the world and we are going to use
the example of cocacola is to say if you
you put to think about the cocacola is a
product that has probably existed
120 years during that time there have been
several world wars the development
of nuclear weapons all kinds of events
unfortunate and tragedies and so
successively but every year the company
knead more fortune earns much more
money from what they earned before and they go to
continue to exist you can be sure
based on the story that this is a
business that will continue to stand almost without
matter if the interest rates are of
14% if the dollar is on the ground and the
gold price is going up or towards
down those are the types of company in
those who want to invest in the long term
companies that are extremely immune
to the events that are
happening in the world another criterion if
they think about our company's positions
lemonade as we grew we had
than to buy more and more posts now
these lemonade stands only cost
300 dollars each but imagine a
business where every time he grew up if
you had to build a new factory
that produce more and more products and those
Factories are real faces because if
well that company could generate a lot
business money for
to be able to grow, we would have to reinvest each
more money in the business, the better
companies are those that do not require
a lot of reinvestment of capital that generates
a lot of money that can be used to
pay dividends to shareholders or
where you can invest in new
attractive high performance projects
I think the last thing I would say is that
they must invest in public companies
It's probably safer to invest in
companies that are not controlled a
Controlled society looks like our
business with lemonade stands
Become a public company
problem with controlled companies is
that except that the majority shareholder
be someone of full confidence and except
that there is someone with excellent
background of handling the so-called
minority investors the
shareholders who do not exercise control
investing in such a company can be a
risky idea because you are at the mercy
of the majority shareholder and for more than
the majority shareholder is someone
with whom you feel comfortable there is no
no assurance that said person
do not sell your controlled shares to another
person who will not be so supportive with
the shareholders of the company then
it's not that you can have a business
profitable a company that has
gone well but you must make sure that
the address and the
who controls the company think of you
as in an owner and they can protect
Your interests
these are some of the criteria in
what to think
good when you're ready to
start investing money I would start from
the same premise that you are a student
you probably have loans
educational maybe you'll even have some
Debt on your credit card passes
graduate you're going to get a job
then if you do not want to start from now
while you already have enough debt
pending begins to invest in the
stock market the stock market is
the ideal place to invest when
you have money that you can save and that
you will not need for five or maybe ten
years then if you're paying rates of
relatively high interest in your
credit card you will surely want
pay the credit cards before
think about investing in the stock market
values ​​your educational credits
probably have a lower cost to
your credit cards but on the other
side in this case my advice would be that
If your educational credits have a
rate of 6 or 7 percent if the liquid
you will surely earn a performance of 6
or 7 percent and it would be better that you can
get rid of the debts of the
credit card and loan
education before consigning a
significant amount of money to the market
stock market even after you settle your
of the credit card assuming that
have liquidated your educational loan is
necessary to have enough money in the
bank so that in the case of staying
without work you have money saved for
6 or up to 12 months let's talk a little bit about
the psychology of the investment then
we already know some of the factors
technicians how to think about how much it is worth
deal
let's say you want to buy a business to
a reasonable price you want to buy a
business that will continue to exist
whenever you have access barriers
to make it difficult for others to compete
with you but all these details are
important and many investors
follow its principles
the problem is to put them into practice
the world panics and the market
stock market is going down every day and
investors see how the
value of their retirement contributions or
your investment account then the
natural tendency is to do the opposite
what it would make sense to do to be
a successful investor you have to be able
avoid some normal tendencies of
human beings like letting you carry
for the others the stock market follows
lowering daily your natural impulse is
to sell when the market goes up all
the days you will be predisposed to
buy then when it comes to
bubble
you would probably be a seller but in
crisis you would become a buyer
you have to have this kind of discipline
you have to be able to withstand the volatility
of the stock market the key to being able to
support market volatility
stock market is to have confidence there
feel confident that you have enough
money in the bank like to not
need what you have invested during
many years that is an essential factor in
second place you have to recognize that a
short term the stock market is what
what we call a voting machine in
the short term really represents the
whims of the people there are many things
affecting the prices of the shares
in the world things happen that really do not
have nothing to do with the value of
certain companies in which you invest
you have to accept the fact that the
value of what you acquire can
decrease considerably after
buy it but that does not mean that
you have made an investment mistake is
only the volatile nature of
stock market how to feel comfortable
with this you do not buy a package of
actions simply because you like the
name of the company you make your own
research reaches a good level of
business understanding you make sure that
it's a business that you understand, you make sure
that the price you are paying is
reasonable
compared to the profits of the
company
let's say this is not for you I do not want
invest I do not want to buy shares
Individuals seems too risky
I do not have the time to do my own
research what are the
Alternatives that are good for you
alternatives with stan in outsource
your investments
make them through third parties you can
hire an investment manager or
You can hire a group of
financial administrators there are several
alternatives for an investor
beginner the most common alternative
they are investment fund companies
which are mutual investment funds
we could say that from the point of
technical view are like a corporation
but where you buy shares in said
corporation and the manager selects a
portfolio of shares then what is
does it is to raise capital money from a
large group of investors
let's say they put together a billion
dollars take the money and invest it
in a diversified range of values
now the benefit of this approach is
that with a small amount of money still
with less than a thousand dollars you can buy
a participation in a portfolio
diversified managed by a manager
professional who receives compensation
for doing a good job for you at
invest in the market
so mutual investment funds
they are good candidates for an investment
the problem is that there must be about 7000
8,000 or perhaps 10,000 different funds and
some are fantastic while
others are not very good
you must find a good administrator
Mutual investment funds as well as you should
do it to find actions
individual then it's not that simple
invest in mutual investment funds
There are some key success factors in
what you should look for to identify
a mutual investment fund or a
financial administrator of the type that
be
first of all you need someone who
have an investment strategy that
make sense to you you must understand what
what they do and how do they know that
they are taking advantage of your insecurity
using complicated words and
expressions that you do not understand if you do not
can explain in two minutes what
they do and how they do it and why it has
meaning then that is a strategy
where you should not invest in
second place and the order is not accurate
this should probably be the first
criteria you need someone with a
good reputation for your integrity if
just start
You probably want to invest in a
Mutual investment fund sponsored by
some of the largest groups
mutualists instead of a small fund
mutual investment supported by a
mutual funds company of which
you've never heard there are some
benefits when investing in institutions
bigger you can have more confidence
that they're not going to steal your money
you need an approach where the
investor invest your money in
value function I know this sounds
pretty obvious but the investment in the
value has a very long trajectory and
then there are other types of investments
including technical investments
where people bet on stocks
according to the price dynamics but I
I recommend not getting close to that kind of
boarding then you need someone
that invest in the sense of buying
companies believing that the prospects to
future of said business are good and that
the price paid compared to the value
of the business represents a discount
important you need to invest together with
a person who has a track record
long I would say that five years of
experience is the absolute minimum of
ideal way would be someone with ten fifteen
twenty years of experience doing
investments in the markets because there
much that can be learned by being
long-term investor in the
market you need someone who has a
consistent approach and that there is not
changed means
what you do every year you have to
see if you have a strategy
formulated that has respected
constantly and that it has helped
get attractive profits during your
investor activity it seems to me that of
somehow the most important thing always
is that you get someone to invest
most of your own money together
to yours
you are going to want to have someone whose
interests correspond to yours if you
it's about a mutual investment fund you're going
to want them to have a lot of money in their
own mutual fund if it is about
a speculative fund that is a fund of
private sale for investors who have
Higher net assets you will want
also administrators that invest
with you
we started with a small business
of lemonade stands the goal of
that example was to offer a basic idea
of how to think of a business that is to say of
where the profits come that are the
income what are the expenses what is a
financial balance what is the statement
of income how to think about how much is worth
a business how to think about the difference
between a good business and a bad business
how debt is generated at a risk
minor and also to a lower performance
as investors in shares buy
the shares or the property on a
company how can you earn more or lose
more we use these details as a basis for
give us an idea of ​​the vocabulary that
employs in the world of investments and
we talk about investments in the
stock market we talk about ways
to think about how to select investments
how to face some of the problems
psychological investments we have
travel pretty terrain in a period
of fairly short time
the title that I have chosen for this
talk is all you need to know about
finance and investments in less
of a good hour that's not really
all you need to know is just one
introduction and I hope not to have you
cheated by convincing you to look at this
for an hour but there are actually
much more to learn and there are some books
wonderful that can teach you
quite about the subject but I think that
the most interesting thing about the investments already
whether they choose this as a career
full time or not is that if they want
succeed in this race must win
money and how to invest that
money will make a big difference in the
quality of life they have and maybe the
quality of life of their children or in the
house they can buy or in the
retirement that they can enjoy we have
talked about the difference between a
10% yield and a yield of
15 or 20% over a very long life and
what impact does this have on the
fortune that can be accumulated in the
respective period then the
investments are important we like or
no and learn more about this will have
a strong impact on their quality of life
if money is something they need to
meet some of your goals
it started to interest me when I had
22 or 23 years ago I started to be interested
investor and I read a book that
called the smart investor was
written by ben graham who is a
famous investor in values ​​is like reading
the essays on the existentialism of
jean-paul sartre you read them and they seem
a whole revelation and affect your life
directly or you're not interested in anything
this book is the same thing but about the
investments I found a book
fascinating what I liked about the
investments was that it's about something
accessible even for someone of 22 or 23
years and what captivated my interest was that
It is one of the few jobs where each
day you can study something new you're
constantly learning about new
business new situations new
management teams new topics
so it's an infinite challenge and the
world and the stock market are
obviously very dynamic places like that
that the challenges continue the same
concepts that are very useful at the time
of deciding how to invest your portfolio are
also useful to contemplate
such as buying a house or
make decisions at work or decide
if you have to hire more people these
types of conjectures and mental processes
they are useful and serve in life and
I recommend learning more
thank you for paying attention and I wish you
the best